Новини дня «heute» з Мітрієм Зіріним.
Добрий вечір усім у найдовший день року.
Новини спорту сьогодні
розповість Крістін Отто.
Добрий вечір.
Теми випуску.
Важка зброя для Києва від Німеччини.
В Україну прибули перші
артилерійські установки «Panzerhaubitze 2000».
Федеральний уряд оприлюднив
повний перелік зброї для України.
Судовий процес
над вбивцею поліцейських.
Підозрюваний, що п'ять
місяців тому застрелив
двох правоохоронців у
місті Кузель, постане перед судом.
Звинувачення у антисемітизмі:
впродовж декількох днів художній
ярмарок потерпає під шквалом критики.
Наразі суперечливу
інсталяцію повністю демонтована.
Війна в Україні триває
вже майже чотири місяці.
Увесь цей час Київ просить Німеччину
нагально надати Україні важку зброю.
Сьогодні міністр оборони
України подякував Німеччині
за поставку самохідних
гаубиць «Panzerhaubitze 2000»,
одних із найсучасніших
артилерійських установок.
Українські солдати пройшли підготовку з
використання цих систем у військових Бундесверу.
Загалом Німеччина
передала Україні сім гаубиць.
Їхня дальність становить десятки кілометрів.
Водночас федеральний уряд
змінив стратегію комунікації
щодо оборони та оприлюднив перелік зброї,
яку Німеччина вже поставила Україні.
Детальніше про це
розкажуть наші кореспондентки.
Шакунтала Банерджі
наразі перебуває у Берліні,
а Катрін Айґендорф -
на Сході України у місті Дніпро.
Отже, як ви можете оцінити
поставки важкої зброї для України
та зміну комінукативної стратегії Німеччини?
Рішення федерального уряду щодо
зміни комунікативної стратегії досить цікаве.
Адже перелік зброї був цілком таємним,
а зараз розміщений у вільному доступі
в інтернеті.
Він складається приблизно з
чотирьох сторінок та містить інформацію
щодо усієї зброї, яку вже доставили та
планують передати Україні:
від індивідуальних перев'язувальних
пакетів до «Panzerhaubitze 2000».
Федеральний уряд пояснює це тим, що
діє як найближчі союзники, наприклад США.
Вони вже давно опублікували
перелік зброї, яку надали Україні.
Втім, складається враження,
що дії уряду - наслідок
довготривалої критики та закликів
до прозорості щодо постачання зброї.
Про це свідчить, зокрема, те,
що сьогодні в Україну прибули
самохідні гаубиці з Німеччини та Нідерландів.
До того ж точно в обіцяний термін.
Однак дебати щодо постачання
зброї триватимуть й надалі.
Союз CDU/CSU зазначив, що потрібно
поставити Україні більше зброї
вищої якості у ще швидші терміни.
Вони планують подати відповідну
резолюцію у федеральний парламент.
Дякую. Катрін, що думають в Україні
про поставки «Panzerhaubitze 2000»?
Насамперед цій новині зраділи
та відчули полегшення
не лише військові, а й цивільні українці.
Справа в тому,
що росіяни мають велику перевагу
в артилерії.
Саме артилерія визначатиме
хід цієї війни.
Це стосується, зокрема, і боротьби на Донбасі.
Там ситуація для українців загострюється.
Вони перебувають в оточенні росіян.
Завдяки поставці
найсучаснішої системи озброєння,
яку Україна вже має у своєму розпорядженні,
українські військові зможуть
зупинити просування росіян
і перемогти у цій війні.
Впродовж наступних днів ми побачимо,
де саме розмістять ці гаубиці.
Наразі це невідомо.
Є регіони, що потерпають від
сильних атак з боку Росії.
Небезпечно було б так
ризикувати і розміщувати їх там.
Тож ми із хвилювання спостерігаємо
за тим, де саме їх застосують.
Дякую.
Поговорімо детальніше
про ситуацію на Донбасі.
Очільник Луганської ОДА має побоювання,
що Москва має намір
захопити регіон на Сході до неділі.
У Сєвєродонецьку проросійські солдати
вторглися у промислову зону.
За даними Києва,
там українські бійці захищають
лише хімічний завод,
у якому перебувають цивільні.
Посилені бої очікуються
також на Півдні країни.
Поки Москва транслює
у Херсоні російське телебачення,
влада України закликає
цивільних евакуюватися звідти.
У Прибалтиці виник новий осередок
конфлікту між ЄС та Росією.
З суботи Литва блокує залізничний транзит
частини вантажів у ексклав Росії - Калінінград.
Цей транзитний маршрут -
єдине сухопутне сполучення
цього регіону із Росією.
Зі свого боку Литва впроваджує санкції ЄС,
що передбачають
заборону імпорту будівельних
матеріалів, вугілля та металів.
Детальніше про це розповість Наталі Штеґер.
Мешканці Калінінграду скуповують
товари у будівельному магазині,
адже Литва більше не дозволяє перевозити
такі товари як метали, сталь та будівельні
матеріали своєю територією
в ексклав Росії на побережжі Балтійського моря.
Незабаром склади опустіють.
Мабуть, зростуть ціни або ми взагалі
більше не зможемо купувати товари,
до яких звикли.
Припиняться будівельні роботи,
зокрема будівництво доріг.
Усе буде гірше.
Досі Росія доставляла
заборонені товари у Калінінград
через територію Литви.
Росія зазначає, що у Калінінграді незабаром
зникне 40-50% товарів.
Водночас Москва погрожує Литві.
На міжвідомчому рівні
розробляються відповідні заходи.
Їх буде вжито
найближчим часом.
Вони матимуть дуже серйозні негативні
наслідки для населення Литви.
Уряд Литви наголошує на тому,
що лише вводить санкції ЄС
з огляду на загарбницьку
війну Росії проти України.
Литва не зацікавлена у загостренні ситуації.
Та є санкції, які необхідно імплементувати.
Цей конфлікт особливо гострий для Берліна.
Німеччина очолює місію НАТО в Литві.
Нещодавно уряд збільшив кількість
військових для захисту позицій.
У ці часи для мене важливо,
щоб усі зрозуміли одну просту річ:
Німеччина - на боці Литви
та усіх наших східних союзників.
Москва повідомила, що через
блокаду транзиту доставлятиме
більше санкційних
товарів у Калінінград морем.
Тож ще один конфлікт між ЄС та Росією -
у самому розпалі.
У Берліні сьогодні відбулася конференція
«Tag der Industrie» («День промисловості»).
Звичайно, не обійшлося без
наслідків війни в Україні.
Цього року Федеральна
спілка німецької промисловості
очікує зростання лише на 1,5%.
Спершу виробництво та торгівлю
сповільнила пандемія коронавірусу,
згодом - глобальні перебої в ланцюгах поставок.
Ці проблеми й досі не вдалося подолати.
Додалися ще й нові:
зростання цін на енергоносії та
загроза припинення
поставок російського газу.
Політики мають намір протидіяти їм і тому
знову обговорюють ядерну енергетику.
Детальніше про це
розповість Карл Гінтерляйтнер.
Йдеться про енергетику,
надійність постачання
та старі рішення, які зараз під питанням.
Сьогодні на конференції
«Tag der Industrie» лідер опозиції Мерц
чітко закликав: варто й надалі
використовувати ядерну енергію.
Нам варто розглянути можливість тривалішого
використання трьох атомних електростанцій,
що залишилися у Німеччині.
Партнер-ліберал сіє
розбрат у «світлофорній коаліції».
Він підтримує опозицію у цьому питанні
та ставить під сумнів
«зелене» табу.
Я хотів би іншого. У довгостроковій перспективі
є сумніви й з погляду економіки.
Однак наразі ми маємо
три справні електростанції, які досі працюють.
Йдеться не лише про одну зиму,
яку нам потрібно вистояти,
а про забезпечення нашого
енергопостачання на наступні три-п'ять років.
Канцлер Шольц висловився проти подальшого
використання ядерної енергії. За його
словами, це просто неможливо.
Експерти єдині у своїх поглядах
щодо використання ядерної енергії.
На їхню думку, паливних стрижнів
вистачить лише до кінця цього року.
Тож немає нікого, хто міг би
запропонувати, як це зробити.
Роберт Габек не сказав нічого щодо
ядерної енергетики, однак дав зрозуміти,
що деякі рішення не хочуть
ухвалювати. З цим нічого не вдієш.
Ми зновумаємо спалювати
більше викопного палива,
враховуючи, скільки нам потрібно на день.
У цьому є необхідність, але
це не те, чого ми хочемо.
Йдеться про запобігання
серйозної економічної кризи,
що загрожує суспільству Німеччини.
Забезпечення безпеки енергопостачання вже
зараз вимагає компромісів.
Тож через загрозу нестачі газу
все більше політиків вимагають
подовжити термін експлуатації
атомних електростанцій.
Та чи дуже це допомогло б?
Наразі працюють три атомні електростанції:
у Нижній Саксонії, Баден-Вюртемберзі та Баварії.
Вони виробляють 6% електроенергії.
15% генерується завдяки природному газу.
Виникає питання: чи можливо взагалі
відмовитися від ядерної енергетики пізніше?
І чи є у цьому сенс?
Детальніше розповість Лютен Лайнгос.
Сьогодні на найбільшій у Європі
спеціалізованій виставці про енергію
в Ессені часто обговорювали
загрозу нестачі газу взимку.
Оператори АЕС мало думають
про подовження терміну
експлуатації атомних електростанцій,
проте на камеру цього не кажуть.
Ядерна енергетика -
технологія великих ризиків,
яку не можна просто
вимкнути і знову увімкнути.
Вона передбачає довготривалу
перевірку сценаріїв вимкнення.
Зі свого боку я як операторка
належно дослідила цю ідею.
Паливні стрижні
на атомних електростанціях
закінчаться до кінця цього року.
Закупівля нових триватиме щонайменше рік.
Проте, на думку представників
«ядерного лобі», шанси є.
Завдяки певним заходам
з використання наявних паливних елементів
ми могли б розтягнути це ще на кілька місяців.
Можливо, доведеться трохи зачекати,
доки будуть доступні нові паливні елементи.
Але на зиму 2023-2024
це питання має бути вирішеним.
І надалі панують сумніви, чи це зрештою
допоможе заощадити газ.
Проблема полягає в тому,
що атомні електростанції
повільно нарощують та зменшують потужність,
тому не вдається задовільнити
основні потреби в електроенергії.
Газові електростанції
працюють з точністю до навпаки.
Їх використовують, коли виникає непередбачена
нагальна потреба в електроенергії,
тому експерти говорять,
що газові електростанції
не можна просто замінити на атомні.
Газові електростанції використовуються
лише за пікових навантажень,
оскільки вони надзвичайно дорогі.
Вони швидко запускаються та вимикаються.
Атомні електростанції ж орієнтовані
на базове навантаження,
тому прямої заміни немає.
Тому добре наповнені газгольдери
не так легко отримати.
Тому що газові та атомні електростанції
занадто різні.
У Кайзерслаутерні сьогодні
перший день суду за вчинок,
який наприкінці січня викликав
глибоку скорботу та жах.
У політиці, суспільстві, а особливо серед колег.
Двоє молодих працівників поліції
були застрелені у Пфальці
під час нічної перевірки транспортних засобів.
Сторона обвинувачення впевнена,
що мотивом вбивці
було приховання свого браконьєрства.
Про початок процесу розповість Крістель Гаас.
Хрест та квіти.
Невеликий меморіал спорудили
за кілька кроків від місця злочину.
На дошці написано «Нас двоє» -
двоє поліцейських, які були вбиті,
тому що виконували свою роботу.
Сьогодні до залу суду вивели
підозрюваного у наручниках.
Його ім'я - Андреас С.
Він вислуховував звинувачення уважно
та без зайвих рухів.
Прокуратура звинувачує 39-річного
головного підозрюваного у подвійному вбивстві
через жадібність, оскільки злочинець хотів
убезпечити свою здобич.
Це сталося 31 січня близько четвертої ранку
На цій дорозі поблизу Куселя
двоє поліцейських хотіли перевірити фургон,
у вантажній зоні якого лежала мертва дичина.
Звичайна рутина.
Але після цього пролунали смертельні постріли
з близької відстані.
Андреас С. сьогодні розповів,
що не лише він стріляв.
Він вистрелив у молодого офіцера
в порядку самооборони,
його спільник Флоріан В., який також
був підозрюваним у суді,
вбив поліцейську.
Адвокат Флоріана В. вважає це брехнею.
Я припускаю, що підсудний хоче
нашкодити моєму підзахисному,
щоб помститись за мої свідчення та співпрацю.
У залі суду присутні також і колеги поліцейських.
Лякає, наскільки небезпечною є ця професія,
особливо у буденних рутинних ситуаціях.
Перший день розгляду справи
про вбивство у Кузелі.
Суд призначив 14-денне засідання.
Ті, хто їздять потягом у Великій Британії,
сьогодні мали великі проблеми.
Десятки тисяч працівників залізниці
провели найбільший страйк
за останні 30 років.
Чотири з п'яти пасажирських потягів не курсували,
а в четвер і суботу плануються чергові страйки.
Працівники вимагають покращення умов праці
та підвищення заробітної плати.
Роботодавець запропонував 3%,
та з огляду на інфляцію у країні,
яка сягла 9%, цього недостатньо.
«Documenta» — одна з найважливіших
художніх виставок у світі.
Після масових звинувачень в антисемітизмі
організатори відступають і знімають
суперечливу індонезійську
художню інсталяцію на полотні.
Протягом кількох днів критики обурені
антиєврейськими образами на картині.
Про дискусії, реакції та наслідки
розповість Петер Тайзен.
Зневажливе покликання на євреїв,
свиняче обличчя з написом «Моссад»,
ізраїльська розвідка.
На думку багатьох відвідувачів «Documenta» -
це явне антисемітське мистецтво.
Тут очевидні антисемітський, антиізраїльський
та расистський мотиви.
А якщо це так очевидно, тоді місто Кассель
не можете надавати цим людям
громадське приміщення.
Кассель виступає за свободу, люди тут відкриті,
тому таке не може відбуватись у цьому місці.
Керівниця «Documenta» під сильним тиском
і сьогодні просить вибачення,
також за індонезійську кураторську команду.
Разом із «Ruangrupa», художнім колективом
та художниками ми запевнили,
що на «Documenta 15» не буде
антисемітських творів.
Інакше ми б негайно втрутилися.
На жаль, ми не дотримали обіцянки,
цього не мало статися.
Ще напередодні «Documenta»
точилися палкі дискусії
на тему антисемітизму.
Якщо хочете знати, напередодні було
багато попереджень
та занепокоєнь з приводу антисемітизму.
А якщо це заздалегідь не взяли до уваги,
то значить і не хотіли.
Після бурхливих протестів
суперечливе полотно закрили.
Сьогодні його мають забрати з міста.
Однак дискусії щодо антисемітизму
на «Documenta» не припиняються.
Спочатку нестерпна спека, а згодом сильні бурі.
У Верхній Баварії одні екстремальні
погодні умови змінюють інші.
У Мосбурзі-ан-дер-Ізар дерева після граду
впали на дорогу, через що загинув велосипедист.
Багато людей поранені.
У місті з 20 тис. жителів та в околицях
зникла електроенергія.
Залізничне сполучення між
Фрайзінгом і Ландсгутом довелося зупинити.
А зараз про спорт та третю срібну медаль
на чемпіонаті світу з плавання в Угорщині.
Прошу, Крістін.
Цим справді можна пишатись.
Флоріану Веллброку не вистачило лише трохи
для перемоги на дистанції 800 метрів
вільним стилем на чемпіонаті світу в Будапешті.
Але у фінальному спринті американець Боббі Фінке
знову випередив його.
Веллброк здобув срібло у новий
рекордний час для Німеччини.
Флоріан Веллброк на четвертій
доріжці цього разу
здобув медаль на дистанції 800 метрів.
За ним - Михайло Романчук з України,
якого Веллброк запросив
разом тренуватись у Магдебурзі.
На шостій доріжці попередній
чемпіон Пальтріньєрі,
а на сьомій - новий олімпійський
чемпіон Боббі Фінке.
Протистояння на останній доріжці,
Романчук - попереду Веллброка та Пальтріньєрі,
Боббі Фінк крайній зліва, американець робить
гігантський фінальний спринт!
Веллброк дихає вправо та бачить лише Романчука.
Він контролює ситуацію та здобуває срібло!
Чемпіон світу попереду німецького плавця.
Олімпійський чемпіон - Боббі Фінк.
Лукас Мацерат щойно фінішував шостим
у фіналі на дистанції 50 метрів брасом.
Маріо Гетце повернувся до Бундесліги.
30-річний півзахисник
перейшов з ФК «Ейндховен»
до переможця Ліги Європи
«Айнтрахт» Франкфурт.
Він підписав контракт на три роки
і «шалено» цьому радий.
З четверга до неділі Берлін знову став ареною
головної національної спортивної події - фіналу.
ZDF та ARD готуються до понад
25 годин прямої трансляції.
Загалом 190 чемпіонських титулів Німеччини
присуджуються в 14 видах спорту, зокрема,
у легкій атлетиці, веслуванні на каное,
триатлоні та стрільбі з лука.
Німецький професійний хокеїст Ніко Штурм
зазнав першої поразки у фіналі плей-офф НХЛ
від «Колорадо Аваланч».
Незважаючи на лідерство, «Колорадо» програв
третю гру на виїзді проти чинного чемпіона
«Тампа-Бей Лайтнінг» з рахунком 6:2.
Щоб виграти Кубок Стенлі, потрібно
чотири перемоги -
«Колорадо» очолює серію з рахунком 2:1.
Продовжимо завтра ввечері.
І нарешті незвичайний аукціон на користь України.
Російський журналіст і критик Кремля
Дмитро Муратов
продав на аукціоні свою
Нобелівську премію миру.
Анонімний учасник заплатив за неї
103 мільйони доларів.
Гроші будуть передані
для українських дітей-біженців.
Цей аукціон закликає до людяності та мужності
в часи війни та кризи.
Завтра на Півночі країни сонячно,
на Півдні ж пройдуть нові грози,
детальніше про це  розповість Кріста Орбен.
О 21:45 рекомендуємо до перегляду
«heute journal» з Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Насолоджуйтесь цим світлим вечором.
Він буде таким ще близько двох годин.
Дякую, що були з нами і до завтра.
Доброго вечора. Сьогодні літнє сонцестояння -
найдовший день у році.
У Мюнхені, наприклад, сьогодні
між сходом і заходом сонця
проходить 16 годин і 4 хвилини.
У Гамбурзі, що далі на північ -
17 годин і 3 хвилини.
Як показує супутникове зображення,
майже весь цей час світило сонце.
Проте з південного заходу
все ж таки насунули хмари.
І саме там сьогодні ввечері та вночі
можуть пройти сильні зливи та грози.
Але лише зрідка.
На Півночі країни
здебільшого ясно, вночі частково
температура знизиться до 7-12°C.
Грозове повітря принесе
м'якші температури, від 13 до 18°C.
Завтра на узбережжях
температура буде близько позначки 20°C,
на решті територій літня температура,
від 25 до 30°C.
На Півночі ще й дуже сонячно.
Тільки в Шлезвіг-Гольштайні трохи
похмуро та туманно.
На Півдні, у Саар, південному Рейнланд-Пфальці,
Баварії та Баден-Вюртемберзі,
очікуються зливи та грози.
Вранці, а потім знову сильніше вдень,
можливі грози з дощем, градом та шквалами.
З четверга погода знову буде
від теплої до спекотної.
Однак у п’ятницю, особливо на Заході країни,
буде сильна грозова негода.
Гарного вечора!